durissimo video sono fa vj devo girare
meno con la sedia sennò poi finito il
video e sono girato di spalle dati su
wall guys e ci alleniamo per il torneo
ci sarà a fine luglio io e step e let's
go tutte quelle cose che tu pensi che si
possa dire nata non ne puoi dire certi
tuoi nba strani ma io sono tu e dove
vivo e quanti anni ho fine va meglio per
caso di tivo e poi in realtà tutto il
resto me ne frega meno degli altri
tutti i prossimi parli famiglia di cose
pa time alle sue incognite stati notai
conta gente sta avvisando di non dire
dove sto andando a vivere adesso che il
trasloco iniziali e ti prego non dirlo
io ad esempio non lo so forse il giorno
mio compleanno
spesso mi succede una cosa su un pre
finito in ospedale una volta no va bene
tutto per giuliano pinto ospedale dove
raccontando yes che stavo aspettando
perché sono morto ed a ma non hai detto
mentre di morte ma sono state molto
calmo ecco questo è bellissimo avere tra
lazio è persino foto questo mi piace un
botto me è uno slide climb fatto un po
più e tecnologico molto buono buonissimo
quando poi fanno un sacco di skip che
non sappiamo bravo di pace è né pinball
questa linea in questo primo pinball
vedi come perché l'altra volta che ho
fatto la lively for guys c'era questa
modalità come casto modalità che potrei
far tipo tre volte e diventava fino a
finale e quindi però giocando l'altro di
andare avanti allora devi a staccarlo
aspettare e dare no sei un pazzo
bravo ma non sono mai stato così tanto
fermo qua certo assicuro bravo ma è
successo anche qui lo skipper tutto a
destra volendo vedi dove saltano addosso
questo pezzo di otto rischio bravissimo
rischiavano bravo e poi di questo il
pezzo finale
certo certo certo certo certo certo
aspetto un'ora nascente vabbè allora
vado niente scende ok
si parte per la finale delle finali
della finalissima
c'è un solo io vado da stefano vai vai a
trovare però non troppo perché primo ha
rischiato propizio quindi eliminiamo la
piattaforma blue qui a papà papà
sento già gente sopra di me come è
possibile non scese di cinque
piattaforme dai che qualcuno alla
piattaforma finale che sta distruggendo
vista davvero è vista temerario
coraggioso ha prezzo ma quasi di più no
dovete proprio no no no no no sì però
non ero io quello che stai dicendo
2 con la mia ski mentre adesso sono
questo qua buongiorno a tutti qua un
casino ma dovrebbero nakata forma breve
era allora abbiamo perso no
madonna sono posto anch'io ma dai
ragazzi li vedi io questo non l'ho
sempre confuso con altri players brown
allora navale che va dall altra parte ha
capito tutto e come si gioca finalmente
non 2 dalla stessa parte esattamente
voglio vedere qualcuno a cadere oltre la
piattaforma blue sei sempre tu lì già si
era semplice buongiorno da perfetto e
vabbè non potevo farci niente dove
cacchio andavo scelta di fatto veramente
pesante si chiama così in fondo no dài
dài sempre a mente è credibile guarda il
lato positivo non è il torneo mondiale
però manca foto è solo un vittoria
bisogna caso anch'io in un brutto posto
io sono stato qualcuno che la guardava
trovato sulla fiducia medica perché la
fiducia funziona vi faremo per te eccolo
qui stiamo qua è un'ottima scelta di
piattaforma ecco è un ottimo inizio
la strada sul mia parte esattamente
perché è sempre vissuto il più possibile
però quando piattaforme va bene deve
essere sempre sotto il nostro speciale
se non va bene
teniamo un po di altezza prime due che
arrivano quelli correlati non ce la
faccio tanto accontenteremo tutti
all'ultimo questa è la classica che
siamo tutti all'ultimo piano è
bravissimo
mammamia giocatori spaziale
termoelettrico e in forma ragazzi qua
anche qua proprio lui tutte le fa tutte
tutte è calma adesso mi corrette addosso
ok ok un altro
ok però c'è ancora tempo rumeno vale
anche se sei chiodi di vita su lungo non
durava dall as one day la finale se
siamo tutti quanti a meno che bisogna un
bel pò di fortuna meno che non capiti su
una piattaforma che regge di più delle
altre ma è raro perché dice che cadono
tutti quanti che si facciano scappare
dell'est del pazzo e quindi io ti direi
che andremo sull'ultima come prima
preview
ecco la prima attenzione
ok ok siete tutti qua
neanche per per lui è rimasto solo uno
al blu o che comunque si è capito che il
più bravo è quello che ti ha fatto
cadere non io nola come avversario di
arte e infatti guarda di nuovo sarà
l'ultimo a cadere da viola perché serve
a poco perché si sa pochissimo vantare
sono detto ok dai solo una è nel giallo
77 in quattro il blu tendevano ma se
quello che potremmo stare tutti essere
durante il torneo per di sì ma sai che
non ho mai capito se singolo oa squadre
è proprio che sarebbe il troppo bello se
questa squadra troppo
vediamo allora e quando sia soprattutto
da solo
bravo ecco un uomo ambiente visto morto
tranqui ora devo solo sperare tanto pd
come il frumento possibile a quello è
morto un altro amore se la giochi con
uno va il più lento possibile perché
siete con gli stessi blocchi
praticamente è vera e sana brava partita
ma sei un pro perché fa tipo il salto
col succo per allentare anche se non so
di che cosa è una roba che a me non
piace perché secondo me ma vai sul
finale si ci sta
sul resto non lo farei perché rischi di
cadere molto più facilmente però si sul
finale quando è così io l'unica roma
cavo per vincere la guerra però siete ai
ragazzi spero vi sia piaciuto e che sia
dischi tia canale perché sono delle
spiacere quel bel bastone con su scritto
iscriviti che non fa mai male
iscrivetevi pensato anche tosto il piace
qua sotto su come migliorare su fall guy
scusi io mi lego tutto e siamo sfilati
al massimo torneo ciao
[Musica]